so as you might have heard florida pass  this law that attempted to prevent  social media platforms from  deplatforming political candidates and  political speech not surprisingly  industry groups have already pushed back  and they're almost certainly going to  win for  at least two reasons first of all  section 230 the infamous communications  decency act  section 230 explicitly allows social  media platforms to  moderate their own content and most  importantly that law preempts  state law it's a federal law that  effectively prevents states from passing  laws like this and then second of all  there is the first amendment these are  private companies and they are largely  in charge of  what speech they allow or don't allow on  their platforms  so it's unlikely that this florida law  is going to last very long because we're  going to see it  in court